So here are the graphs that match up with each of the functions. You might
notice that two of these graphs actually didn't change at all. From the way
they looked when their corresponding functions didn't have absolute value signs
in them. Those two graphs are B and C. So what does this mean? Well, you'll
note that in both functions g and k, the absolute value signs appeared around x
squares. Now we know that x squared on it's own is always going to be positive.
So taking the absolute value sign of a positive number doesn't do anything to
change it's value. That's why these two graphs don't change at all, compared to
the old versions. We put absolut value signs around the denominatro of the
function 1 over x. We can see that the branch that used to be down here with
negative x and negative y values. Got flipped across the x axis. So now, it's y
values are positive. I think that graph d might actually be the most
interesting change of these four. Before, we just had a straight line. This is
basically just the function. F of x equals 1. A constant function. But now, our
numerator will always be positive. But, once we move over into the negative x
values. The denominator will be negative. A positive divided by a negative
makes a negative, which is why this half of the line got reflected across the x
axis to become negative. Pretty cool.